so the date is December 11th in 2017
were almost at 2018 and we wanted to
give so many bands and champions of the
movement and opportunity to connect with
these two fine gentlemen and good
friends of mine David Mead and Peter
docker the co-authors of find your why
how's it going guys
lovely people awesome fantastic so here
is what's gonna happen in this call the
focus of this conversation at least our
intention is for us to focus on
discovering your individual why of
course we want to engage with you guys
as much as possible so we will give you
an opportunity to ask any questions you
have about the concepts of starting with
why anything you've you've heard read
seen from these two guys and of course
our founder Simon as well we're gonna
kick off by doing a couple of poll
questions just to understand who's here
what your level of experience is with
our work and our content so that you
know as as my wonderful friend Peter
doctor says context is everything so
before we move into content and
answering any questions let's get the
context right let's learn a little bit
about you I'll be it through a poll
before we we dive in and start answering
questions we do have a couple questions
that we have prepared so many people
wrote in both to our website and on
social media so we'll start there and
then we will open it up and really hear
from you guys you can type in your
questions using the Q&A and we will dive
into those questions so before we go any
further I want to introduce a few people
first and foremost I'm gonna put him on
the spot because he is working behind
the scenes and he you actually if you've
written into our website you probably
heard back from him his name his name is
Jeffrey Braun and he is going to be
handling all the Q&A behind the scenes
so Jeff I'm putting you on the spot but
if you could maybe come off video and
just way
to the thousands of people we have here
there is hey Jeff
everybody we we like to affectionately
refer to Jeff as the voice of the
movement because he has a fantastic
voice he also has a baritone because
he's an opera singer did you know that
so Jeff is gonna be working behind the
scenes curating the questions that are
that are coming in and you will hear his
voice when we pull a question because
myself Peter and David want to be
focused on the conversation and not be
pulled off they're suggesting to help us
out there like I said we also have
Laurie and Sharon who are helping us
behind the scenes um next is my esteemed
pleasure to introduce my two great great
friends and colleagues Peter dr. and
David Mead they worked with Simon to go
to co-author finder Y which I hope a lot
of you have in your hands and have had a
chance to to dissect and even if you
don't you know this is you're still in
the right conversation so long as you
showed up for the Y call if you showed
up for a different call you might be in
the wrong place we will talk about house
and watts as well but this is the
finding you're why I call Peter doctor
spent 25 years in the Royal Air Force
rising to the rank of Group captain and
he learned much of his firsthand
leadership experience for being in
service in that line of work and when he
left the Royal Air Force he was
committed to continuing to live a life
of service as we're all designed to do
with human beings and he actually wrote
a message in to mr. David Meade who at
the time must have been what six seven
years ago was doing the job that Jeff
was doing when we were a smaller still
mighty with smaller team and David I've
heard you say that Peter just felt a
little bit different he was showing up
to give showing up not only to give but
to get it so that he could give to
others and lo and behold a friendship
began with the two of you and Peter
since what 2011 you've been speaking and
facilitating and coaching and consulting
combining your own experiences and
content with with leadership as well
was assignments so there's Peter docker
hello everybody good to be here
yeah and peter is in the UK and my other
dear dear friend mr. David Mead who's in
Salt Lake David is the one who actually
hired me so six years ago seven years
ago I wrote into the website and David
responded to me and he saw that I was
much older and smarter than I actually
am he asked me to join him in doing to
start with my podcasts which we we we
did and got 16 episodes out of the world
and and David went out to speak and
facilitate and I filled his shoes doing
customer service which Jeff now does so
I wouldn't be here if it weren't for you
mr. David Mead so thank you for that and
David what's really awesome about him is
he was a is and was a huge champion of
this message she worked for a startup
company that really was clear on its why
and unfortunately wasn't as necessarily
disciplined in its house and though they
stood for something good they weren't
living the message of perhaps Simon's
second book leaders elast they weren't
really creating that culture where
people could essentially live what
leadership was preaching and so David is
spawn chica mitad to ensuring that we
live what we preach and he fortunately
at Simon and our CEO Kim did some
consulting at that company this startup
that he was at and he had an opportunity
to to join them you were you were
working mornings and nights for a while
with them and joined full-time how many
years ago is that David since 2009 is
when I started a part-time vein so yeah
wonderful
so that's David Mead and Peter docker
and for those of you that I have not met
I'm Steven chocolate ski and I'm our
team's chief of staff so what I love
about my job is that I get to ensure
that and I work hard to ensure that what
we preach on a stage we live inside of
our company we have a small but mighty
team we're up to 23 people now and I get
to ensure that we live our message from
the inside out and it is
a treat to be able to be doing this
reaching thousands of people to propel
the movement forward and to help you
guys be more useful with with the work
that we love so so pumped that you're
out here so guys let's start with that
poll question to learn more about all
the people that are joining us
I think Laurie as our host Laurie behind
the scenes can you pull up those poll
questions for us
I'm sure Laurie is working for the
frivolously behind the scenes to get
those going here we go
so our first poll question is where are
you in your why discovery journey we'll
keep this open for about 30 seconds and
let us know do you know your why and
like I said Peter dr. get it - give it
are you trying to help others find
theirs are you so ecstatic to know your
own why or maybe maybe not ecstatic
maybe confused who knows do you know
your why but want to work on that
language are you in the process of
discovering or why or you don't yet know
your why so take a second fill that in
it just gives us great information to
know where the majority of you are at in
your journey and Laurie I'll let you
close that when we've heard from most of
our participants here
you
yes David and Peter you guys can answer
to here I'm going to put my answer in
all right Laurie how are we doing
oh look at that very cool so 45 percent
of you 600 people are in the process
process of discovering your why great so
we can probably talk about some partner
stuff more of the the journey almost 200
of you not only know your why but your
art you are inspired to help others find
theirs we love to see that yeah in lorry
week we can see it this is great and 4%
of you know your why hopefully at the
end of this call more will be inspired
to go in that journey and wow a good
chunk don't yet know your why it's so
great you've come to the right place and
we can definitely help all of you and
hopefully address everyone here
wonderful so we have one more poll
question that we are gonna put out there
it says a lot of you are in the process
of discovering your why so keen to know
the tools that you're using so the next
poll question please Lorie I see Peter
taking notes here wonderful so one more
question here what if any why discovery
tools have you used and you can select
more than one so are you using the
finder why book we also have the online
course which Peter and David are a huge
part of as well perhaps your company has
hosted a why discovery workshop with
with our team or you've attended we've
just started doing public workshops so
we've done it this year in New York
Chicago Fort Worth Atlanta and Los
Angeles perhaps something else and
another tool you're using or perhaps
this is your first step so we'd love to
know what tools if any you guys are
using on your journey to discover your
why so we'll wait a few more seconds
here and see what comes back Peter David
any insights you guys have is we're
seeing this come in I'm just thrilled so
many P
in the process and there's a good chunk
of folk so looking forward to helping
others to discover their why yeah which
you know is always a wonderful thing to
see and if you guys had your hands on
the on the book finder why you there is
a section in there by Simon that this is
the help others movement not the
self-help movement so David was there
something you wanted to throw in as well
no I was kind of surprised that there
are so many people that don't know
they're Wyatt or that are still pretty
early on in the journey which I love so
glad that all those folks here wonderful
all right Laurie should we do a drumroll
and see
drum roll comes up we have a lot of
people go close to 600 people who have
fun July the book that's fantastic
handful in the online why discovery
course which is great something else
cool and this is my first step almost 50
percent of you Wow fantastic who
delighted you guys are here and what I
love most about our organization is that
we show up to give so anything that we
we can do to help you we're going to do
it so we hope that this our conversation
puts you in the right direction and of
course should you have any further
questions that we didn't address we're
happy to help as well whether it's on
social media or our website so I got a
couple questions for you guys before we
open up the Q&A the first question I
have with you guys is that this is your
first book
it's just launched in September I know
there's a lot of people who probably
don't yet have their book in hand in the
hands but the reason you wrote the book
is to help people discover their why and
I think everyone on this call is here
for that to discover live share their
why so I'm interested to know what has
been your most meaningful experience now
that this book that has been years in
the making is out into the world so I'm
curious to know Peter do you want to
start off sure I think like anyone who's
experienced writing a book let alone
doing it cooperatively cooperatively to
other wonderful people it's a chance
and you get to the stage where you're
wondering if it's ever gonna come out
and then of course it does and you see
it for that first time store somewhere
or going through an airport somewhere
and that's wonderful I think for me the
thing that that completely knocked me
over was a little while ago I bought a
new back book and as many of you know
you get a free 30 minutes genius call
with somebody who can tell you all the
the new new tricks and tips with that
MacBook and so I have my call and it's
random it's you get a genius from
anywhere in the world and this guy came
on and let's just say who was from
somewhere else in Europe and after we'd
gone through the session for about 25
minutes he said can I ask you know what
what I knew you were working you in so I
explained to him and I mentioned Simon
and he went Simon he went silence at the
end of the phone and I then mentioned
find you why in the book and he said I
can't believe it I said well he said
well I've just been approached by the
publisher in this particular country to
translate your book into another
language
now the likelihood of that happening is
so my neuts it just blew me away but I
I'm I'm so grateful for people like this
guy who do translate our words into so
many languages I think there's about 10
different languages the book will come
out and if it's not out already and that
just helps us reach people that David I
wouldn't otherwise be able to reach but
yeah you could have locked me over with
a feather there it was an awesome moment
that's fantastic
David yeah my my experience is a little
closer to home
this startup company where I was working
in 2009 where I initially met Simon I
worked with a guy there named Todd and
didn't you know didn't get to know him
all that well but over the years even
after both of us left that company who
stayed in touch we did much every once
Wow Todd his life coach
also helps recovering substance abuse
addicts and this is the work that he
does now and he has been so such a
champion of this the white movement and
helping these folks who are recovering
you know they recover they get clean and
then they think to themselves like we'll
shoot like we're maybe with the rest of
my life like you know why do I get out
of bed every day and so he's
incorporated this into his work and I've
been able to do some of my discoveries
for some of his and some of the folks
that he coaches and it's just been an
amazing experience Todd's story ended up
in the book and so one of the most it's
just kind of interesting how a came full
circle and it's really meaningful he
came over to my house to pick up his
copy that had been signed by Simon by
myself and just to give him that knowing
kind of you know what he's doing and how
meaningful this work is to him and to be
able to give him a copy of a book that
he never in his wildest imagination
would have guessed he would be a part of
it was just a really really special
experience with other members for a long
time that's amazing that's fantastic
so one a complete stranger and the other
David someone you've known for quite a
long time that's really neat so I'm Jeff
I'm gonna pull you out and let us know I
know we had a number of questions that
came in leading up to this and I can see
over 40 questions that have already come
in in our Q&A functionality so I'm gonna
ask you Jeff if you'll come off me and
just let us know a question we've had
that's come in sure yeah I'd love to
alright so the first one I want to ask
we got actually a couple questions about
this so some people are having difficult
finding a partner to exercise to do the
exercises in the book is there any
recommendation on how to find a better
partnership people try and do this by
themselves fantastic so partnering David
go for it
yeah often so simple answer to the
question question should we try to do
this by yourself our selves no please do
not try to do it by yourself the way we
we sort of you know we compare it to
right we cannot conduct those therapy
sessions on our own not that this is a
therapy session it's something different
than that however an outside perspective
that sort of third party viewpoint is so
incredibly important because what we're
looking for and why discovery is pattern
recognition and in these different
stories that were telling to be able to
pinpoint what are the things that are
the same what is that golden thread that
runs through everything and it's very
very very difficult if not impossible to
do that for ourselves and so if you're
having a little bit of trouble with that
and I've experienced this as well I've
got you know a couple of family members
that have gone through this process and
have said I just I don't know who to ask
my suggestion would be in Peter I'm
interested to hear your take on this but
I think if we can get past the
perception that there I I don't know who
to ask there's nobody I can ask and and
not worrying so much about well you know
I'm afraid to ask this person because
what does they think this is weird or
you know what what if you know do I have
to know them you know extremely well or
all this stuff but I think we kind of
get in the way if we really kind of take
that bigger perspective that bigger
picture you go up to 30,000 feet and say
look this is something really important
to me I want to be able to get up every
day and know the purpose behind the work
that I do or to look keeps me busy
throughout the day and sharing that just
sharing that experience that you're
going through might just be inspiring to
somebody that you know to the point
where they would be more than happy er
more than excited to help you to help
you do that and so I think maybe just
letting go of the perception that well
they probably wouldn't do it or they
would think it was strange or those that
kind of thing I think we probably all
have a few people in our lives that that
could serve that purpose but Peter I'm
curious to hear what your response to
that would be when
starting the the why discovery journey
because as you say in the book ideally
you need someone that you feel you can
trust but also perhaps not your lifelong
partner or someone who's very close to
you because they may already have
preconceived ideas of where the stories
that you're going to share where they're
going to go and there's one person said
to me either when I cross off the list
all those people that I'm not left with
anyone well I think as the advice is in
the book you know think of five people
that you would be willing to be a
partner for and that's probably your
shortlist why I go step further I was
absolutely blown away a month or so ago
in New Orleans where I ran a shorts
kick-starts to find your wine and that
they were probably about 60 or 70 people
in the room who did not know each other
and yes we just paid people up and they
started sharing stories with one another
so if you if you hear someone perhaps on
the Facebook channel maybe who's also
looking for a partner just an idea maybe
you can be in service of one another and
sometimes not knowing that person well
but that person just being willing to be
in service for you and you can be for
them it can actually work out pretty
well and certainly within the hour of
this short session we did in New Orleans
people walked out
I mean arms sometimes with people that
they just started to share stories with
but previously you're now before they
didn't know them so it doesn't have to
be somebody you know it can be somebody
who is looking for a partner in just the
same way as you so yes keep all options
open but definitely have a partner
because even for likes David and me and
I'm sure for you Steven talking within
our team has helped us further refine
our y2 so yes that objective view always
always helps wonderful and yeah it's
your point Peter we've seen people even
on our Facebook page
say I don't have a partner to work with
and someone's volunteered and said I'll
work with you
so there's another opportunity we do
require a partner for that objective
perspective so we love
seeing the ways that people do find
partners even within our own community
Jeff what's next
all right we've had about four people
right in asking should they read it
start your start with why before reading
find your why
you
I'll hop in on this it's up to you we're
not going to say to people sit down and
read start with why from cover to cover
first if you're eager to to get on with
find your white then that's fine we
wrote in the front of find your wires
sort of synopsis shorter version of
start with why this isn't about selling
books either if you want to read start
with why borrow one you know it's you
don't have to go and buy one I'm sure
there's plenty in the libraries around
the world too
having said that if you want the deeper
appreciation of the power of the golden
circle and how it can help and influence
us both in our individual lives and in
business too then start with why the
book does certainly go a little bit
deeper it's entirely up to you reading
start with Y is not a prerequisite for
launching it to find your Y but you will
get a deeper appreciation of the ideas
if you read both David anything do I
would you agree absolutely I compare it
to you know when you buy a new gadget or
a new piece of technology usually
there's like the manual which is you
know sometimes online for those people
who just and then there's the QuickStart
guide which a lot of people are like
sweet let me just just tell me how you
know give me the basics that I need to
be able to figure out how to use this
thing so the information that we get
around the golden circle and start with
why the QuickStart guide is in finder
why so you'll have you know if and it
was written to be a standalone book so
you will have the basic foundation that
you need as far as the knowledge about
the golden circle and the concept of why
if you just pick up find your why but
for those of you who love that level of
detail
start with why is good good place to go
yeah and we have even seen some some
comments and book reviews around this is
this is not a simon Sinek think ii think
ebook and the answer is no it's not
start with wise assignments in a kinky
book and this is finder y which is a
practical how-to guide that's how this
book is written is to be used as a as a
guide book that's why there's room and
room in the margins so to your point
guys awesome Jeff what do we have next
all right when we pull my face back up
here all right Stephanie W asked so how
do you find your Y when you are
passionate about several things do you
have to nail it down to one thing
without feeling you are bending all
those other passions as well wonderful
so the question of passions and why
David go for it yeah I'll take a stab at
it so what I often find is when I'm
helping individuals find there why is
there that are passionate about many
different things or you know they're
really excited about something for a
while and then the interest changes in
thereunto something else so they have a
hard time figuring out well you know
what what's my life seems to change or
it shifts or I'm you know passionate
about so many different things that
don't seem to have anything comment on
them and I think that the skill and the
the practice of this and again the the
benefit of having that third party
observer that partner that we produce so
much to have is that really the goal is
to get above all of those things and
rather than figuring out what makes all
those things different all those things
that are so seemingly different that I'm
passionate about rising above that and
figuring out what is it that ties all
those things together and this is what
the Y discovery process can really help
you do is to figure out the commonality
and then basically all of those
different things that you're passionate
about are you're less and so what we got
to figure out is what is the underlying
thing that brings all those things
together that when you do one of those
things that just lights you up it fills
you up it fulfills you there's likely
commonality among most of all of those
things that tie into your mind speed or
anything to add there yeah I just adults
that the process of the wine discovery
actually what you're doing is is finding
your themes which are your house and the
one that rises to the top is your Y so
Stephanie's your point you know you may
find that you're you're coming up with
all these stories that the do seem to be
a number of themes well that's part of
the process and as you go through it
you'll find that of those themes they'll
be fine maybe six and it's a sixth one
that rises to the top to become your why
there's no difference between your wine
your house
than the why is the first amongst equals
if you like so there are gonna be a
number of different themes that you
discover as you go through your your
wine discovery process that's part of
the process it's certainly when you get
to the ends and follow it all the way
through that you figure out which one is
the one that's that it's the root of
your why so keep going I'd encourage you
I love her there's two points here to
close this guy's around Simon has a
great quote on I'm passion and also our
previous point around the value of
objectivity David what you were saying
that sometimes you know when we focus on
all the things that that we love we
can't find the common thread of course
we can't because we can't see the forest
from her from the trees and we're in our
own why discovery and also Simon has the
quote of we only have one passion but we
have many watts to that passion right
there are many ways we can bring that
passion to life which is our why so as
you both said wonderful Jeff what do we
have next
all right Madeline Elle asks how do I
figure out which memories to use in the
Y discovery great so the the Y discovery
process is you guys may or may not know
is based upon our past it's who we are
and where we come from which are all
about our memories or our stories which
is what is being referred to so guys how
do you know which ones are the right
stories well I don't think there's a
right or wrong story the thing is when
we we ask people to look at the stories
from their lives the most important
aspect of this tour is that the is that
they are specific by specific we mean
talking about we mean a story that talks
about a particular time a particular
place particular people because when we
talk about specific stories it triggers
an emotion in our brain and that's how
those memories are are formed in the
first place we remember things because
they are in tune with a particular value
or belief that we hold and that's what
triggers the the memory process so it's
not a case I think of signing which
stories use the more stories the better
if provided they are specific stories
that's the most important thing
and then tell us many of those stories
your partners you feel you need before
the themes start to emerge and if you
feel that you really want to tell one
other story then chances are it's really
quite important so tell that story you
don't need to limit yourself and you
certainly don't need to decide which
story to leave out in which to tell the
most important thing is they're specific
and they're likely then to have that
nuggets of goals that you're looking for
which will point to also themes which
will point you towards your my David I
would just say one other thing which is
go with your gut don't overthink it
whenever a story pops into your mind
that's significant that has meaning for
some reason write it down whether you
decide to tell it or not at least record
it and have it there and just the last
point is you know often we think about
well the stories that I tell her these
memories that I I'm considering using
they have to be something big or
something monumental absolutely not they
have to be meaningful and significant
and that can be the smallest little was
seemingly insignificant thing but if it
means something to you and you remember
it you'll remember it for a reason
so go with your gut the one thing I'll
add in here guys is sometimes we'll see
people enter into the why discovery
process and they've curated their
stories right they've strategically
picked their stories to prove to their
partner what they're why is and if you
truly want to find your why you'll
actually be surprised by what
experiences and stories you shared so to
the question the right stories are the
ones that come up in the moment that
feel that they matter to share as you
don't highlighted awesome wonderful Jeff
do you have another one that comes up
yeah sure so on the same themes issue
what if what if the themes are coming up
with their negative wonderful so we we
talk about peaks and valleys guys but
David do you want to kick off in terms
of those themes sure there are certain
we know as we as we consider those
memories and those stories those
experiences from our pasts
you know not everyone has had a bunch of
really positive fulfilling great
experiences and so that's absolutely
fine we can work with with with the
challenges with the things that have
been tough and what we tell people what
we be seeing it's find is that the
negative themes are a representation of
something that was missing when we're
not feeling at our best when we're not
fulfilled when we're not finding meaning
and there's that overarching theme it's
because something that we need or
something that would fulfill us if it
were there is not there and so often it
sort of represents the opposite of what
we need in order to feel fulfilled and
so we can still use those those are
still valuable stories this is not all
about I'm just just talking about all
the positive wonderful experiences
obviously a why is positive it's
generative it's supposed to be inspiring
and at the same time those those stories
that we sometimes perceive is
challenging or negative or the themes
that seem to come out as a negative
theme simply can kind of be the opposite
of something else that we would need in
order to feel yeah I agree with that
some of you who've heard me speak may
have heard me talk it will tell the
story of Dylan a friend of my my
children and Dylan was almost killed in
a motorbike accident now at the time
that was an extremely distressing
negative story if you like however the
positive that he's drawn out of that in
terms of why does what he does has been
extraordinary so all of these stories we
can often find something positive from
them in terms of what we were able to go
on and do or go on to be and then it
just acts as further reformation or
reaffirmation of who we are and our
values and what we believe so all of
these stories whether positive or
negative to help us point to that why
and sometimes again it's the partner who
can identify the the positive points if
you like from that negative story who we
became how we grow how we grew from that
that particular event so again your
partner who's your friend yeah one of
the things we talk about guys and we run
these workshops is you don't have to
share something you don't want
to share but if it feels like a little
bit of a risk to risk to share its most
likely a good thing to top into so in
terms of which stories to share
Laurie let me know guys that we are
receiving a number of questions in terms
of programs for business of course Jeff
Jeff pulls up a question about it we can
chat about it but just wanted to let you
guys know that if you are interested
about what programs we do run for
business you're more than welcome to
check out our web site start with why
comm and if you'd like you can submit a
speaking or workshop request and someone
from our inspired solutions team will
get back in touch so that's just to
mention that so I so I remember to do it
I want to do it right now Jeff what else
do you have coming through the queue my
friend all right so we've got a lot of
questions asking about how they can
either apply their Y to their current
job or apply their Y to finding a job so
I've just discovered my wife clarity of
what my Y is and my question is how do I
apply it to my current job or how do I
find a new one that's more in line
potentially with with my Y we'd like to
kick us off well I'll start I think the
wonderful thing about just coming or Y
is that once you've discovered it and
you've put it into that single sentence
it then gives you a new lens to look
through and everything that you do in
your life and until you've discovered
that why it's difficult to to figure out
how you're going to use it and what
difference it can make and I I had to
tell the story of John the the reporter
in a hospital and the hospital was very
clear on its wires an organization which
was around enabling their communities to
thrive and John you know he just pushed
people on on patients on trolleys on
Gurney's that's what he did
but then he obviously had discovered his
why because in his interpretation of
what he did through the lens of that Y
was that he saved people's lives as he
said to me quite
sadly unless you push those people on
those trolleys those Gurney's from the
emergency room up to the operating
theater then the doctors wouldn't be
able to do their job and those people
would often die so you know he'd work
that out through knowing the overarching
Y of the organization and through
through having insight into his own Y so
quite often these things just start to
smack you know fit in the face when
you've got that Y sentence you can start
using it as a filter for everything and
it's it's actually Molly for me as well
times when I'm feeling down or a bit off
for a bit low I can reach for that Y of
mine and it's all about enabling people
and I can I can just have myself go out
and enable somebody through a
conversation somebody you meet on the
streets it doesn't have to be big often
the most significant thing is very small
so in my experience it quickly becomes
apparent how you can use this in your
everyday life regardless of whether it's
your job or just linking with with
friends or family or in a social social
events so David
over to you sure I would say you know
sometimes Y may point directly to some
sort of you know job or some sort of
industry and it might be a very clear
tie so for example you know if my Y or
to you know to share knowledge so that
the you know the eyes of people can be
open to the world around them like that
might be perfect if I'm looking for a
teaching job for example right like that
might just smack a elementary school
teacher or might not like if that's not
my passion I can still share knowledge
so that the people so that I open eyes
you know the eyes of people to the world
around them I can do that in any
situation that I'm in but we're finding
more and more is that it's less about
finding arrives to be able to find a
particular job or a particular position
this is a very human and better aware
when we
who we are when we are at our natural
best as Peter says we can do that at
work you can do that and the community
we can do that with friends or at home
and the opportunity that we have is to
do that even in the existing job that we
have so just because we discover our why
we don't see a natural tie between the
words that we came up with and the
current role that we have it doesn't
mean we have to quit and go look for
something else it just means that we
have an opportunity to show up in a
little different way at work and to be
that best version of ourselves for the
people around us and to create that
environment through who we are being
because we now are conscious of our Y
and the contribution that we make I
would just add a footnote to that which
is our Y is a route to leadership often
we're talking about leadership in terms
of an organization a team or a company
but in English we have that phrase you
know to lead one's own life and that
takes courage and when you take your Y
statements and use it as a filter for
everything you do it's the first step
really to be able to have that courage
that's the source of courage to lead
your life and leading your life standing
it for what it is you believe in and
being the leader sometimes that you wish
you have regardless the situation you're
in whenever you're interacting with
people you have a choice now you can
lead your life through your Y and
support those around you and do what
we're biologically hardwired to do to
support others so both to your points
guys are why is a perspective so it can
take the current job we're in and we can
move towards the things we love and try
to get off our plate the things that
drain us or that we don't love and the
beauty is somebody else loves that that
is somebody else's Golden Circle they're
at their Winehouse David what I loved
that you shared was that ye y example to
share knowledge what was it o to share
knowledge so that the eyes of others can
be open to the world around them
something like that so I see that's not
your wife statement
with that that could be a
photojournalist it could be so many
watts right so I love that you gave the
example that could be perfect for an
elementary school teacher but again it
doesn't matter what you do it matters
why you do it well why is the context
for the contents of our life
Connor and on sex gives meaning to
everything that we do all of that
content so that's the look at the last
thing I'm going to say guys and then we
have a special request that I'll ask in
a second is sometimes our Y is aligned
but our house aren't right Anheuser just
as important so our good friend Jen
Waldman who does speaking and
facilitating for us as well she's taught
me that when she feels out of balance
the first place she often looks as her
house right in her house are the actions
we take to be at our best or values in
action and oftentimes she'll say her why
is a line but there's a relationship or
a system or something that isn't meeting
one of her house and that's one of the
places she she goes and Peter as you
said when we do this why discovery
process the first thing we get is our
house and then one of them tends one or
two tend to rise higher which which are
candidates for a Y that said guys we've
had a number of requests to here each of
our Y statements and maybe even a couple
of our house if you feel up to it
so David do you want to share your your
Y and maybe one or two of your house
sure so my Y is to propel people forward
so that they can make their mark on the
world and just blowing got out a little
bit
the thing that just fills me up fires me
up gets me going is when I can help
somebody just be a little bit better
than they were the day before not
talking about monumental change I'm just
talking about just that one step forward
and the word propel is extremely
important to me because I'm not I'm not
physically pushing I'm not pulling I
think of a propeller which just causes
you to move it's not physically touching
you so it's just in a way just creating
the environment or creating the space
for people to be able to take that one
step closer to where they want to be so
that they can be amazing
in the world a couple of my hounds that
really stick out for me learn from every
experience I'm a huge learner and if I
don't learn I can't help propel others
the other one is to see the big picture
I have to understand the context in
which I'm working for me to be able to
be at my best so those are a couple of
the house that really okay for me my why
is to enable people to be extraordinary
says they can do extraordinary things
and so to enable this the root of that
and I can I can bring this suit to life
through so many different things that I
have done in my life you know it's the
root of my why but enabling people is
the key and I bite in saying more about
this extraordinary piece though because
it's about enabling people to do
extraordinary things that are
extraordinary for them and so these they
can don't have to be huge things but
extraordinary in their eyes be able to
go that extra step be able to achieve
more than they thought was ever possible
and actually I've just reached over we
talked about having a simple and this is
a gift from the wonderful limb start
with white theme it's a compass and if
you look at my website there's a story
behind the compass but this is a
representation of my why and it reminds
me that I'm about enabling people and
helping people find their way and to
achieve more than they thought possible
my house actually I share some of them
with with David certainly seen the big
picture side of it one of my other house
is to simplify I like to try and
simplify it because as Leonardo da Vinci
said simplicity is the greatest
sophistication is not always easy but if
we can simplify things that everyone can
understand and everyone can can share
and I hope that we've done a little bit
of that in this book and another one is
to go the extra mile to to do that extra
piece of work to push a little bit
further to help people just a little bit
more so that's one of my house and just
because we've got these house written
down doesn't mean to say we're perfect
all the time you know it's always
working progress and Steve I think you
bring
a great point from Jim Wellman you know
sometimes we're out of our house and we
just gotta work on it a little bit more
but so yeah hopefully that answers the
question good I love Peter you got the
compass you got the book I'm wondering
what else you're gonna put out pull out
next you got all the things next day
that's great I can share my why my why
is to engage people in meaningful ways
so that we more deeply connect I believe
that when we more deeply connect to
ourselves the people around us in the
world around us fear than a live in a
more fulfilled world so that what's
that's what drives and inspires me and a
handful of my house I love communicating
so articulate what we feel see and know
you know communicating to get on the
same page and stay on the same page I
love that look forward which to me is
optimism it's also why we're talking
about symbols which is the next way to
live are why I have orange shoelaces on
multiple pairs of my shoes that's why
that that way when I catch myself
looking down at the floor in a less
confident position I see it as bright
orange which reminds me to look forward
and to choose a positive perspective
keep it fresh and new I love variety and
another one is give to the hungry I love
feeding people who want who are hungry
for more and who want to improve which
is why I love this very call that we're
on because everyone here is hungry for
this and once
wants to do more and give more so I love
that all right Jeff we haven't heard
your voice in far too long what else do
you have my friend
alright analyse T and Kurt W both ask
can you have more than one why and will
it change over time
great so before we dive into that answer
we do have about 15 minutes left maybe
less if we don't get to your question we
will still curate all the questions that
have come in and we'll try to provide an
answer whether it's a video or something
so and more webinars to come in 2018 so
that question guys who wants to go first
David yeah I'll go first
and I'll try to be as brief as I can
because I see the number of questions
continuing to rise I'll only get to as
many as we can analyse incurred thank
you for the question the we only have
one why and again this is a matter of
perspective right so a lot sometimes we
think one of the big things that we see
is that people say well my family is my
wife your family is actually one of your
was it's it's one of the opportunities
that you have to show up and live your
why your why is much bigger than that
the way that I like to think about it is
we are who we are wherever we are and
that is at work at home with our friends
in the community anywhere that we are
our Y is the same we are ourselves we
are our best selves no matter what
situation we're in we have the
opportunity to be we're not always so we
only have one why for work for home for
everywhere and I will leave the second
half of the question of does our Y ever
change to Peter okay so why the words
were used in the Y can morph over time
but the feeling behind them doesn't
change so for example the first part of
my Y to enable people it used to be to
enable others and then I changed others
to people because in my mind people
including myself too and sometimes for
me to better enable others perhaps after
a busy traveling schedule or whatever I
need just to label myself a little bit
so the word people included myself too
so yes the words might morph over time I
think David you you've you've changed
one or two your words over the few years
we've known one another
you know just one or two just and that's
okay
it's the feeling behind it the words as
we know the the the Y comes from our
limbic part of the brain responsible for
all behavior all decision-making it's
got no capacity for language so at the
very best our Y statements is the
approximation and expression of the
feeling that lies behind our wise so
it's quite likely that the the words
will change but the feeling won't and to
David's point we only have one way one
way only yeah and words are imperfect
words are a representation for a meaning
so I've even heard some people you know
in organizations or individuals say
that's not a word you can't use it
people have actually made up words to
put into the wide statement that means
something to them so it's all based on
our stories in each word like an
accordion when we open it up they have
deep significance and meaning so we have
one way and one way only it covers all
the what's we love and though the
language can change the meaning in
essence of the Y is the same Peter did
you have more Don yeah I just answer
that because in a wise thing there's
only a few words and those words that we
use often have so much more meaning than
if we look those words up in a
dictionary and so over the years my why
the meaning of those words it's taken on
more meaning day after day as I do all I
can to live my wire so in a way the
words are becoming less important it's
that feeling behind them and words are a
tool to help you live it just one quick
story here guys is when when my daughter
Sophie was born a mentor of mine said to
me you have a new Y and I went same Y
now just a bigger platform a bigger
stage to go live it it means more now so
huge life events or even tragedies don't
change our Y it just gives us a new
perspective lense platform to live it
Jeff what else do we got we have about
ten more minutes so let's see if we can
do it's certainly a couple more
questions here all right Jonathan G asks
what are some signals that may indicate
you have deviated from your why hmm
great question what are some signals
you've deviated from your why Peter
you're off mute so I'll go to you first
yeah
it will feel wrong it will you know you
you're why is a it comes from our limbic
brain it's a feeling it's based on
feelings we know when we are acting in a
way that's not consistent with what we
believe you know if we we have a
conversation with someone or we react in
a certain way we will feel uncomfortable
it's we're emotional animals this is how
we are hardwired and so our emotions are
going to tell us it's from to the center
when we're acting outside of our Y of
course the Y can also give us a way to
choose to act as well so as we can be
proactive that's the idea of it but yeah
I would say you will know when you're
acting outside of your Y and it would be
a very good reminder David yeah just to
tack on a little bit to that which is
you know sometimes we have to make a
decision that throws us out of balance a
little bit there's an immediate need you
know we lose our job we've got to have
money to pay rent and so we go get a job
that maybe isn't perfectly in line with
our line right we will feel that that's
not the place for us it's like this is
not the most fulfilling place for me to
be and yet just in the immediate
short-term that's what we need in order
to take care of our family pay our bills
whatever it is the beauty of that is
that we recognize that and the goal is
to get back into balance and even it's
not something that extreme even if we
just you know have an experience like
Peter talked about where it just it just
doesn't feel right and we know it it's a
great trigger for us to realize well
what do we need to do to get back in
balance we will not be at our best every
single day we don't perfectly live on
why every single day when we get those
little cues from our limbic brain that
let us know that something just doesn't
feel right that's a good reminder for us
to figure out again use our lion house
as filter to figure out what isn't right
what's not
driving here and how do we work to get
back into balance so that we can get
that feeling of fulfillment and meaning
the very simple and neat thing is that
everything we do everything will we say
either asked to or takes away from our
why even if we don't have words for our
why you know people our friends will see
us acting out of character is quite
often what we all will say if people are
doing something that seems wrong for who
they are so everything we say everything
we do either adds to or takes away from
our our why and with it we answer the
trust and loyalty that people feel
towards us so when we've got that wise
statement which is the contribution and
the impact that we can make in the world
it gives us a really good steer on the
choices we can make to always add to
that's that why bring it to life add to
the trust and loyalty that people feel
towards us I'll even add on guys the
perspective Peter just to what you you
just said around you know it's clarity
of why discipline of how and consistency
of what right and one of the things
that's consistency of what is yes indeed
the friends you choose and so one of the
things that happens when we discover ry
is we really get clear on this is who I
am and this is one knot then we might
actually create some meaningful changes
and sometimes friends will go you aren't
who you are and you've changed and it's
an opportunity for you to check in with
yourself and with the people who you
love and trust around what makes you
proud and what makes you embarrassed
that in that internal compass if you're
proud chances are you're living or why
if you're not proud or embarrassed
chances are you're not and so even as we
shift um some people who we considered
friends because we've known them for a
long time from college or whatever you
know as we as we evolve and live into
our why sometimes we have to be very
mindful of the relationships we choose
as well any comments to that as well or
seeing a couple nodding heads which
means that might be saying something
decent they're just one thing maybe not
directly related to a said but this idea
that we all have a why whether we have
words for it or not and we all know when
we're living it and when we're not which
is this again this gut feel
that we get that we are doing something
that matters that we're finding
fulfillment something that we love
something that we you know are
passionate to wake up and do everyday if
that's how we're feeling we're living in
line with our why and now the
opportunity has just put words to that
so that we can do other things that
bring that same feeling but I want to
make sure that nobody on the call thinks
that they have to have a wise statement
in order to have a why mm-my statement
is simply just maybe with an
articulation of that feeling so that we
can more consciously and intentionally
do it moving forward rather than having
it happen by accident awesome and David
to the point you shared previously this
was a quote I read of Simon's about
seven years ago which inspired me to
make some big changes you said sometimes
you know you purposely are cognizant ly
or consciously make a make a choice that
might be out of alignment but it's for a
specific reason so there's a code of
assignment around the difference between
sacrifice and torture have sacrifices we
do something for a known period of time
for a very good a common good but if one
of those two pieces are missing either
the known period or the common good it
can easily become torture so it's where
it's okay to consciously make a
sacrifice in order to achieve something
better and even a known timeframe and if
not it could easily become torture one
thing I'm getting from Jeff is a request
the three ingredients to live are why
right we call it start with why not end
with why we start with our clarity of
why our discipline of how and our
consistency of what so clarity of why if
we do not know what our why is we can
you
I'll just I'll hop in here first even
where he looks like we're having some
some internet issues here so clarity of
why what Steven was saying is if we
don't know if we're not clear on what
our own y is there's no waiver no way
for us to limit or to share it with
others the discipline of how that second
piece and again the house are the the
actions that we take the daily behaviors
that we engage in to make sure that we
are living our Y and if we're not being
disciplined in doing that and the reason
we say discipline is because starting
with Y and living that is not always the
easy decision to make
sometimes we have to do things that will
hurt us in the short term but when we
act in alignment with our house that
naturally allows us to be at our best
which allows us to live our lives so
it's having discipline of how and the
third piece the consistency of what
means that everything that we view our
job our relationships our the way we
communicate anything that would that is
the manifestation or a representation of
the things we say or the things we do
must be consistent with what we believe
and this is where authenticity comes in
we talk a lot about that and how this is
you know how we make friends how we date
how we get married all these things the
relationships that we create the trust
that we do is because we can feel we can
tell but the things that people are
saying and doing are in line with what
they believe that's what consistency of
what means so Steven with that all
that's my go to you thanks David good
thing I'm on a call with you guys you
can have my back when internet concept
so thanks there so um we are at time I
imagine that you likely asked a question
if you're listening to this you perhaps
asked a question that didn't get
answered but we will work as a team to
look through those see if there are any
common themes and we'll shoot some
videos or something and try to get those
questions out to you and to the world or
steer you to a resource that already
exists before we thank everyone for
joining us I just want to see if you
guys have any final words in terms of
discovering and living your why Peter
just say that it takes courage to learn
your why to discover it it takes courage
to live it because it's about standing
up for what it is you believe and when
you choose to take on that courage to
find that courage and to go through the
process and get to even the imperfect
why statements you can then start to be
intentional about making those choices
that are going to make you feel
fulfilled that are going to attract
trust and loyalty from others and it
really is a huge reward so I just
encourage everybody who started this
journey to continue down the path
although it will be tricky at times
David I would just say you know a lot of
people us included get really inspired
and really excited when we have this
conversation and so the tendency
sometimes is to say I want to find my
why and start living it as quickly as
possible I would urge you to be patient
with yourself this is a process this
takes time for some people it comes very
naturally very quickly for other people
myself included it took me six years to
come up with the right words for my why
the feeling never changed but I just I
never had the words that I loved and
that's okay it's not about having the
perfect words it's about knowing what it
feels like and making it actionable
so as long as you have that be patient
the right words will come or the words
that feel the most authentic tea will
come
don't try there's no shortcut for this
vacation and that's the guy who wrote
the book on it so if it takes you less
than six years you're doing just fine
I just want to share in terms of closing
words that one of the things I love is
the thing that's the common thread
between all of our work and Simon's work
which is this notion that together is
better there was someone who wrote in
asking if they could believe they're in
Switzerland if they could tune in to the
webinar which I hope they're still on
right now and actually have it in a
conference room and have a number of
people join them and watch them to which
our answer is yes yes yes CSS yes this
is the help others movement and that
indeed if you want to go anywhere with
this go together write the the the
proverb if you want to go go
fast go alone but if you want to go far
go together so if you care about this
stuff just find one other person who
cares about it too and help them and
they'll help you Laurie just put in
methods to find your wife so we're
getting a lot of requests so what
methods are there to find your y-you
know one of the things we have is the
friends exercise which you can find on
our website start with y comm there's
the book that these guys wrote there's
the online course that these guys have
but truly we also have live events and
you can write into our website and check
that out but the the fun trick is take
out a napkin draw peaks and valleys what
are the experiences you've loved what
are the experiences in your life
throughout your entire life from your
earliest childhood memory up until this
very moment that we're all so
challenging and share those experiences
one by one with someone who you trust
and your themes will emerge if you want
a bit more guide rails or you know a
bowling alley with those guides on the
side we have tons of tools that are all
sourced to help so guys thank you so
much Peter and David for forgiving of
your time and for sharing sharing a
couple thousand people who joined us
which is fantastic and can I say
Steven is this this guy's the voice on
the audio version of finds your why's so
which I know is very popular with a
voice like that well we've got some good
voices on this team what can I say yeah
thank you should they say I have a face
for radio so there it is thank you so
much for the over 2000 people who joined
us the movement is strong we show up
every day to serve others and we know
that those of you who are still on this
call do the very same thing so thank you
so much for joining this finding your
why live webinar we'll see you again in
2018 that's for sure thank you
you